among the main reasons that families
with young children move out of cities
and into suburbs is that urban areas
often have terrible schools cities lose
people and working parents face long
commutes back into downtown there's a
cost to the environment too as more
infrastructure has to be built to serve
people spread out over larger areas
partly danielson a business professor at
North Carolina State says one of the
ways to change all that is to provide
more school choice in cities your basic
case for school choice increasing school
choice is that it would allow families
and cities with school-aged children to
stay in the city rather than expanding
out into the suburbs that's in a
nutshell the argument talk about the
environmentalist dimension of this first
why is it good to keep people in cities
let me give you an example here I used
to live in naperville illinois but I
worked in Chicago I worked in Chicago at
DePaul University naperville's 30 miles
away the reason i was in naperville was
the schools are good there I had
children so I was willing to make the
sacrifice make this long commute there
are thousands and thousands of people in
Chicago making the same commute
congesting the roads creating co2
emissions other pollution there's a
tremendous amount of money spent on
infrastructure just to get people from
where they lived where they work if
people could live near where they work
then their lives would be better and the
lives of the people in cities would be
better the ones that are currently being
left behind in not just bad schools but
concentrated poverty what are the
numbers that you have that show that you
know X number of people are motivated to
leave a particular area at because of
that well one of the things you can look
at is the number of five to nine year
olds in an area compared to the number
zero to four year olds in naperville
there are forty percent more five to
nine year olds and zero to four year
olds that's across the country there's a
one-to-one ratio there okay a lot of
people moving to naperville right when
kids start school why the schools are
very good they've been losing five year
olds for decades and the population of
Chicago has been shrinking for decades
so tax base is going round in a school
choice charter schools have been around
now for almost 20 years you know in
places in districts or in areas where
there's a lot of online education where
there's a lot of charter school where
there's more choice than there used to
be do you see those residential patterns
change it so we have a grant from the
National Endowment for the Arts to study
a school in Santa Ana California which
is in Orange County the Orange County
School of the Arts santa ana is
relatively poor ninety percent minority
the school moved there from Los Alamitos
and Los Alamitos really said we don't
want that here because you're bringing
in kids from across the lines and los
alamitos is a prosperous town already
those lines on the ground working pretty
well for Santa Ana had problems the
mayor of Santa Ana looked over and said
we don't have we don't we don't have
traffic problems here and we wish we did
why don't you come here and they moved
into a building on main street in santa
ana and then they grew spectacularly
there almost 2,000 students in the
Orange County School of the Arts but the
mayor was really visionary and names
Miguel Pulido really visionary he
brought in two other charter schools
today in an area that was really
completely blighted there are 3500
children going to school within two
blocks of main street in an addition the
entire downtown area has begun to
revitalize a lot of people don't even
realize what was their first that
charter school that came in when nothing
else would and the reason it did was
because the rents were really low and
they needed cheap space what do you say
to people who are you know well you know
the real reason that schools in in
cities are terrible is because we're not
spending enough money on them if we just
pump more money and maybe even taking it
from the suburb from the suburban
districts pump them into the existing
schools and then problem solved well
I'll give you another example Kansas
City Missouri back in the late 1960s
Kansas City had seventy seven thousand
children the Kansas
school system this year it's less than
17,000 where did the other 60,000
children go well if you look out in
overland park there thirty-three percent
more five to nine year olds a zero to
four year olds out there and that and
that school districts almost as big as
Kansas City School District now at one
point Kansas City spent more money per
student than any school system in the
country it was impossible to spend
enough to keep people from moving out of
the city because people wanted choices
Bart thanks for talking to us it's a
really fascinating argument it so you
know when you talk about school choice
when you talk about environmentalism a
lot of times you don't hear new things
this is totally a novel way of thinking
about the issue well when I first
presented this sort of idea at a
conference to economists I had to
economist later say you know it's really
obvious I didn't think of it and and
almost everyone I've talked to since and
said it's really obvious and I don't
know if I consulted or not yeah it's
really obvious that's like the highest
compliment right that it's really
obvious that I didn't think of it well
thank you so much mark danielson